This is Jocko podcast number
one 41 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
[inaudible] good evening.
Yeah.
March 15th,
yeah,
most loving and kind father and mother,
my humble duty remembered unto you,
trusting in God.
You are in good health and I pray,
remember my love on to my brother Joseph
and thank him for his kindness that I
found at his hand in London.
Okay.
I know loving father and I do confess,
yeah,
that I was an undue TOEFL child unto you
when I live there with you and buy you
for which I am much
sorrowful and grieved for it.
Trusting in God that he will guide me,
that I will never offend you so any
more and I trust in God that you will
forgive me for it.
My writing unto you is to
let you understand what a
country this new England is
where we live.
Here are but a few Indians,
a great part of them died this winter.
It was thought it was of the plague.
Here is timber,
good store and Acorns,
good store and here is good store of fish.
If we had boats to go for
it in lines to surf fishing.
People here are subject
to diseases for there,
for here.
200 odd have died of scurvy and of the
burning fever and beside as many lie
lame,
all Sudbury men are dead but three
and three women and some children.
Yeah.
Here is no cloth to be had
to make no apparel and shoes.
Yeah.
So I pray father send me four or five
yards of cloth to make some apparel and
loving father though I be far distant
from you yet I pray you remember me as
your child and we do not
know how long we may subsist.
I pray.
Do not put away your shop stuff for,
I think that in the end if I live,
it must be my living for we do not know
how long this plantation will stand.
God has taken away the
Chiefest Stud in the land,
Mr. Johnson and the lady Arabella,
his wife,
which was the cheapest man of a state
in the land and one that would have done
most good.
Yeah.
So father I pray consider of my cause
for here will be but a very poor thing.
No being without loving father your
help with provisions from Old England.
Okay.
I thought to come home in this ship from
my provisions were almost all spent but
that I humbly thank you for your great
love and kindness and sending some
provisions or else I should and
mine have been half famished.
But now I will if it please
God that I have my health,
I will plant what corn I can.
My Wife Remembers her humble duty unto
you and to my mother and my love to
brother Joseph.
Thus I leave you to the
protection of all mighty God,
Watertown,
New England.
And that is an unsigned letter
from,
as I said,
1631 so these are settlers
coming into New England,
the f,
the letters written back to a father
and England and obviously written from a
place called New England,
which is where I grew up and where I am
in the woods of right now in Franklin
county, Maine. And we have a guest
today that is also a new Englander,
a Jujitsu black belt,
the business owner,
and a friend of mine by
the name of Peter Roberts.
He's been on the podcast before.
So if you haven't listened to podcast
93 yet and you need to go get the
backstory of how I met Peter and
how this little deal got underway,
go listen to podcasts 93 and
then you can come back here
and listen to the rest of
this one. So here we go. Pete,
welcome back.
Thanks for having me.
And I'm extremely honored to be back
on and was a little bit nervous to come
back on. But uh, after all
your razzing and you know,
motivating and flanking me
and after what you just read,
I'm ready to go. Yeah, we got it pretty
easy compared to those guys. Holy Shit.
Yeah. And it's interesting because you
know I live in southern California.
Echo as we know is from Hawaii.
Sure.
And what's the temperature variation
in Hawaii? In what inmate? No, no,
in Hawaii. How much does the temperature?
Very. Oh, one decree. Just kidding.
I Dunno. 10 year round,
something like that.
25 I think in the past three days there
was a 40 degree change here in the
weather in Maine.
We went from 90 to 50 yeah,
it absolutely gives you a false
sense of hope. One day actually
these people that settled here clearly
were some sturdy stock that came up here.
You think about what they went through
and leaving the comforts of England.
And what I was thinking about is it's not
like these were woodsmen from England,
right? No you weren't hunters
from England. I mean I'm
sure some of them were,
but they were people from England,
from London and then they were all of a
sudden surrounded by this and you can't
prepare for like if there's nothing you
can do conditioning wise to prepare for
this, you just, you, you get
here and you survive, you know,
and that's what they're doing.
I know you're talking about like,
cause his dad had sent him provisions.
That was his insurance policy. You know,
I mean, hey, here's what we can offer you.
And I never thought about on the other
side side of things as a parent like
that, who knows what they would
they had for work or jobs,
who knows if they sent them
everything they had financially,
what they could afford to send their
son to keep him alive in New England.
And you've got a pretty much fixed geared
that when your kid sales across the
sea in 1631, you are never going to
see them again. Right, right, right.
You've got to figure you're
never gonna see him again. Yeah.
That's gotta be the thought. Um, all
right, so welcome back. Like I said,
now last podcasts, obviously
we talked about origin, boom.
And we talked about where it started,
how it started,
the trials and tribulations to say the
least that you went through getting it to
that point.
But it's been a pretty,
so you weren't on the podcast one year
ago because we were up at this origin
camp one year ago and now
you're back on it again.
But it's been a big gear
than a huge benefit.
Been a big year of growth for the company.
How many people?
We've grown by another 30 people.
So total,
we're like 40 plus
people. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think this time last year we
were, yeah, right around 12 to 15.
And we, you know, you
know what is crazy is,
I don't know if I told you this
this time last year, like I don't,
I don't get real,
I'm stressed out this time.
Last year we had the immersion
camp, right. We had a,
the grand opening and the factory,
we had just moved a 60,000 square foot
factory into our factory like w like two
or three weeks prior.
And it was still moving into and there
were some other things going on with
business or whatever. And, and I,
I don't know if I told you this one
night I left camp during the, during,
can't not tell me that I
left camp and went home.
I was by myself and my family was still
here and I was laying in bed and I
couldn't, uh, I couldn't get to sleep
and I just felt really weird. Like my,
my body felt weird and
all of a sudden my heart,
I felt like it was beating through my
chest and I was like, what is going on?
Come to find out I had an anxiety attack.
Never had it in my life.
I haven't had 1 cents and there was
more going on. Does that actually mean?
I don't even know what that,
oh dude, I had never, I mean,
sounds like some of the echo 38 or
38 years, you're cruising super hard.
38 years old.